[Music]
will do that would love to continue this
little theme that we started on because
I know your fans always like to hear
this stuff is like talk to me about your
last 10 years of relationships I know
that's tough but like a lesson lessons
learned like for let me just start off
with a 30-second version my lessons
learned are find someone that you're
always on the same team with so knowing
that you're together in this versus
fighting someone or having to like you
know have your own side is a big one and
the second thing for me was therapy like
therapy and what got me here today in a
very happy positive relationship is
Daria and I at multiple times went to a
therapist and sat down and had a third
party kind of analyzed and helped us
work through some ins issues so that we
could figure out how to be on the same
team but I'd love to hear like I mean
I've known you personally for a long
time so I've seen you through all types
of ladies oh yeah we have we've mutually
assured destruction on this one if
either has no go nuclear but we have
seen we've watched each other with many
different relationships and trials and
tribulations and learning learning
moments teachable moments I would say
that looking back there are a few things
that are very present for me now that
may have come through some really bad
decisions in the past and also just just
kind of mileage right I mean you start
to realize better what you need over
time also yeah polarity number one I
would say is extremely important and
what do you mean by player we could
spend a lot of time discussing various
ways to consider polarity but what I
mean by that is let's just say you have
a sliding scale and this is probably
gonna get me in all sorts of trouble so
for people listening I don't care if
you're martian us-japanese male/female
trans in between there there are
different types of polarity and I'm
going to use probably a heteronormative
language so if you want to crucify me go
for it but let's just say you have a
slider that goes out this way and
right in the middle you have not as
related to an Anatomy but rather
characteristics what let's arbitrarily
call like pure and drogyny in the center
ok and then you have feminine
characteristics and let's just assume
for the sake of argument that each
person is going to decide for them what
that means but feminine characteristics
this direction masculine characteristics
this direction so you have sort of and
then what I have observed for myself and
also in a lot of my friends is that it's
it's sometimes very helpful to find
someone who is equally far away from
that middle point in the opposite
direction right so if you have someone
who is maybe hyper excessively developed
in terms of masculine traits however you
want to look at that very often they're
gonna pair well from what I've seen with
someone who is as far in the opposite
direction
and likewise like this right and there
are there books that they just got that
discuss this I read the way of the
superior man a hundred years ago by
David data which talks a lot about this
I don't agree with everything in that
book but I do think polarity maintaining
polarity enhancing polarity which can be
done through any number of different
practices or reframes that I think is
very important for maintaining a
relationship where there is intense
attraction and healthy a healthy sex
life for it for instance right I think
that's very important is this one two
would be and this relates to what you
said
having structure for cultivating the
relationship that could come in the form
of therapy it could come in the form of
having it say a date night once a week
having a couples day once a quarter
which I do with my girlfriend where we
spend a day talking very candidly about
the things we like the things were
afraid of sort of fears desires
boundaries negotiating new things
testing new things setter and we spent
an entire day doing that it's blocked
out and it's
in advance that's gonna be once a
quarter we have different types of say
systems if you want to call that for
cultivating the garden before it's in
trouble
does that make sense I think that in it
for a long time all was well until there
was a Code Red and things would devolve
people wouldn't say things they needed
to say and resentment might build and
then something would explode and yes
then everyone is firefighting trying to
figure it out and by that point emotions
have run so high elbows are coming out
and it and it doesn't mean both sides
but very often elbows would come out
from someone and it would just devolve
very quickly so how do you handle when
when you have these because everyone has
disagreements and they have these little
things that may rub them the wrong way
when you're in a relationship and
there's this balance between you know
taking everything personally and just
you know constantly responding back to
your partner being like I didn't like
this I didn't like that it didn't like
this and then it becomes this like
little nitpicky yeah type of
relationship versus you know some of it
you may want to just bundle up and
discuss at a later point in time like
how do you know when something reaches a
certain threshold to where you bring it
up with your significant other yeah I
have fun and I don't I don't mention my
girlfriend's name because the Internet's
[ __ ] crazy so I like to try to
protect her you guys are both public
figures so it's part of the game in a
sense for you guys but in any sense or
in any case I should say it that's why
I'm referring to my girlfriend is my
girlfriend but she and I generally will
batch and I think that's in large part
because I'm very sensitive I'm a
sensitive guy in a lot of ways and I
don't use sensitive I used to view that
word in a very negative light a very
negative connotation because we think oh
he's so sensitive meaning he or she
takes everything personally
but I had it one of my closest friends
who you've met actually before asked me
maybe two years ago he said when did you
know that you were really sensitive and
the question really confused me and I'm
gonna get back to the relationship and
timing question what I realized is my
instrumentation in certain ways is just
very very sensitive it's almost like a
scale it just has more decimal points
for certain things and I find a lot of
stimulation overwhelming and for that
reason so at a young age I learned how
to turn that off or numb that
sensitivity but I don't want to do that
in a relationship out so I've over time
in the last 10 years also learned that
turning off or compartmentalizing
emotionally is short term effective long
term very destructive me coming back to
the timing question so I'm still very
sensitive to having things I might
perceive as criticism or suggestions
that require me to make decisions coming
at me at like 3 p.m. on a weekday if I'm
in the middle of some type of phone call
or project or writing whatever it might
be and there are there are some timing
solutions to that they're also
structural solutions right so my
girlfriend tends to work at home and I
work downtown I have a separate place
that I use for work that in and of
itself solves a lot of problems and
right and it's in its and you don't have
to figure it all out being within 20
feet of each other at all times like
that is a perfectly valid answer right
so that's one number two is that we will
block out time so it will block out two
hours or three hours in a given night
I'm making this up but let's just say
once every two weeks where we'll do
batching and the format of that is not
what we tested in the beginning which
was like let's voice all of our
complaints but when we started with that
in other words this like litany of
charges against each other in the
beginning it it poisoned the well and
turned into very unpleasant
experience for both of us that we didn't
look forward to right we kind of dreaded
doing it and my girlfriend suggested a
much better format some like damn good
news takes care of itself let's just
like tell me the bad news it turns out
yeah that's also pretty
counterproductive in a lot of cases so
we start with what we think the other
person is doing really well
since the last batching session and what
they're paying attention to and what
we'd like then we will talk about what
we think we are doing well personally as
a partner and then what we would like
more of and the phrasing is really
important right it's not what you're
[ __ ] up it's what I would love more
of so sort of positive reinforcement if
we're thinking about it like dog
training right you're trying to shape a
behavior instead of whacking the dog
with a newspaper you're giving a little
Scooby Snack to push them in the right
direction when they get something
approximately right and that's the
format so we do that and what's
important to us at least may be
important to me important to both of us
as we take notes so if there are
commitments that are made or important
points that are brought up we have
something that we can then refer to
before the next batching session and we
can see or homework wasn't done yeah and
if something that's that's really
powerful just to have that I mean that I
like the way that you structured that
because I could see very quickly how
that could just be a negative kind of
[ __ ] if you don't have that
structure around it yeah yeah and I'm
and I'm extremely lucky that my
girlfriend's a very clean fighter
that's something I've also learned is
extremely important because the good
times are the good times but yes I heard
someone I don't remember who said this
but the quote is not that adversity
builds character but adversity reveals
character and
you really want to know that your
partner can navigate rough emotional
waters when things are difficult and not
immediately pull out a gun and shoot you
in the face no yeah I mean I'm very
fortunate there - that's something that
Daria has taught me a lot is that it
just were you coming from in this
discussion like where if it's a from a
place of I want us to be stronger and
better together and we are on the same
team trying to solve the same problem
yeah then it's a it's it's very
constructive versus of being about
tearing down someone yeah there's a
there's a framework that the conscious
leadership group uses Jim Detmer diana
chapman and so on that i like quite a
lot i was introduced to their book which
i think is the 15 commitments of
conscious leadership by Dustin Moskovitz
a long time ago a couple years ago and
they have this concept of being above
the line or below the line and I'll let
people look it up if they're interested
but it's a very easy way to check in
with yourself or with someone else to
see how they are engaging in a
conversation or how you're engaging in a
conversation and if it's likely to go
sideways or if it's more likely to be
constructive and so the phrasing they
use is above the line or below line and
I have found all of these helpful and I
think in part what I'm trying to say is
that what what's important is not that
you use exactly someone else's system or
someone else's habits but that you think
about developing and using systems or
structure of some type mm-hmm yeah I
mean so many people out there and I was
one of these people as well just believe
that if you find the right person
everything will be fine you know I was
always like looking for that perfect
person and it just it just doesn't exist
no like we're unique creatures and so
you know the second you can realize that
and then you realize well I do need a
framework for this you're just going to
be in such a better place
you